[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette édition spéciale sur tv fil 78 ans
semble nous allons revenir sur les
résultats de ce premier tour de
l'élection législative dans les yvelines
12 circonscriptions et douze candidats
en tête
le tsunami république en marche s'est
aussi abattu dans les yvelines les
avances de certains sont parfois
considérables à être département ancré à
droite que les yvelines pourraient donc
basculer dimanche prochain les députés
aient l'air vont tenter de mobiliser les
abstentionnistes pour certains cela sera
très difficile exemple dans la 10e
circonscription
l'ancien candidat à la primaire de la
droite pour la présidentielle jean
frédéric poisson a du parti
chrétien-démocrate n'atteint pas les 20%
et il n'y aura aucun député socialiste
issu des yvelines dans la nouvelle
assemblée à l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle député sortant de la 11e
circonscription
benoît hamon a lui aussi été éliminé dès
ce premier tour
le principal enseignement de ce scrutin
c'est aussi avant tout l abstention
51,29 % en france c'est un peu mieux
dans les yvelines avec 47 45 % le
département qui a donc mieux voter que
la moyenne c'est assez habituel mais il
y à de nombreuses différences d'une
circonscription à l'autre on y viendra
dans un instant auparavant écouté
quelques réactions à la sortie des
bureaux de vote dimanche après-midi les
présidentielles c'est vraiment une
figure
voix et tout de suite au grand voile
c'est le président les députés on les
voit pas donc du côté médiatique fait
pas du tout attention se rendent
beaucoup en compte de ce qui se passe et
lois qui sont votées on sait pas
vraiment parti donc oui les législatives
déjà c'est un mot qui parle beaucoup
moins en fait toutes les lois qui sont
appliquées ne concerne pas ni une fin on
se rend pas compte ça pas vraiment
d'impact sur notre quotidien on ne voit
pas en fait on voit pas ce que ça va
changer donc allés voter ou non pour
nous les jeunes ça change rien dans la
vie on n'a pas à choisir tout le temps
entre blancs et noirs
on n'a pas toujours c'est trop facile de
choisir quelque chose qu'on veut ou
qu'on veut pas à quel point faut choisir
faut choisir
voilà c'est tout je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une question d'âge peut être une
question de tradition et d'éducation
familiale aussi ça la fait partie des
libertés qui ont été conquises depuis
longtemps et il faut y aller même si on
n'a pas toujours au bout du compte ce
qu'on veut c'est notre vie de quartier
c'est notre vie de tous les jours c'est
aussi notre politique très très proches
tous les jours
c'est important pour moi c'est important
oui je pense
ton éducation à la base a la base je
dirais pratiquement presque au collège
quand on fait des cours d'éducation
civique tu sais aussi les préparer en
tant qu'électeur et de c'est tellement
important de d'avoir une identité des
lecteurs quelque part pour moi c'est
important d'ailleurs j'ai élevé mes
enfants dans ce concept là d'autres
chiffres à vous donner concernant
l'abstention attrape tout d'abord 62 71
% à des électeurs ne se sont pas à
déplacer aux urnes une situation et qui
a très certainement joué dans
l'élimination dès le premier tour d'un
ancien conseiller municipal de la
commune benoît hamon dans la 11e
circonscription donc nous en parlerons
plus en détail tout à l'heure regarder
ce chiffre qui résume justement la
situation 50,87 ont sans abstention dans
la 11e en revanche à noter que dans
d'autres circonscription des yvelines on
a plutôt bien voter notamment dans la
deuxième qui couvrent vélizy ou encore
magny les hameaux où l'abstention ne
dépasse pas les 41,66 % abstention ou
pas la république en marche et en tout
cas en tête dans l'es12 circonscription
des yvelines je vous le disais en titre
un tsunami à l'image de ce qui s'est
passé dans le reste du pays
écoutez la réaction et d'asie ce
françois n'diaye c'est le coordinateur
en marche dans l les yvelines aziz
françois n'diaye qui était hier sur ce
plateau en direct les français ont quand
même voté même s'il ya une faible il une
forte fort taux d'abstention les
français ont voté et se sont exprimés et
ne se sont pas exprimés en faveur de
l'extrême droite et je m'en réjouis
il ne s'agit pas de triomphalisme nous
sommes dans l'humilité la plus totale
nous serons à l'écouté de toutes les
formations et nous souhaitons et nous en
nous et en nous tendant la main à tous
pour travailler ensemble ce qu'il faut
aussi relever le pays
nous avons des défis énormes qui nous
attend pour les ténors de la droite dans
les yvelines 2 à réaction celle de
valérie pécresse elle appelle un sursaut
est dimanche prochain pour éviter un
parti hégémonique un parti unique
une pensée unique et quant à pierre
bédier président du département des
yvelines il s'est exprimé via un
communiqué au cours duquel il explique
n'oublions pas que si le pouvoir rend
fou le pouvoir absolu rend absolument
fou et puis toujours à droite écouter à
présent christine boutin c'est
l'ancienne présidente du parti chrétien
démocrate
conseillère départementale des yvelines
et donc je suis excessivement il ya
quelques temps la france parce que
donner tous les pouvoirs un seul homme
et à une seule assemblée avec des gens
qui n'ont pas l'expérience me semble
excessivement inquiétant et donc moi je
souhaite c'est un premier tour c'est pas
un deuxième tour il y aura un deuxième
tour et il faut que les français se
réveillent kiffa de droite de gauche et
qu'ils fassent obstruction à cette vague
et à ce tsunami
parce que là nous allons vers un état
totalitaire je n'ai pas peur de le dire
enfin un modèle à gauche et de ce manque
d'union au premier tour des regrets et
le constat est partagé par leurs
représentants d'europe écologie les
verts et du parti communiste français
il ya une vraiment une frange de la
gauche de partir en ordre dispersé on
avait sur la 11e 30 circonscriptions un
candidat socialiste soutenue par europe
ecologie les verts un candidat
communiste un candidat de la france
transmise aussi au bout d'un moment
nécessairement la dispersion des voix
face à une montée énorme de république
en marche fait qu' il y avait très peu
de chances d'être au second tour et
c'est vrai dans à peu près toutes les
circonscriptions des yvelines on n'a pas
été suffisamment intelligent pour un
moment ce dire stop ça suffit donc tous
les précaires
tous les agriculteurs tous ceux qui sont
licenciés tous les chômeurs que tous
ensemble et ce mouvement pour dire ça
suffit la casse du code du travail va
toucher tout le monde va toucher tout le
monde donc c'est important qu'on arrive
à cette unité là pour faire face à des
dérives dans le détail à présent des
résultats des différentes
circonscriptions des
ziv les nous allons commencer par la
première avec vous michael et demi
d'euro bonds soa également sur ce
plateau à nicolas landry bonsoir à vous
et sur nicolas bon soin ensemble donc
nous allons faire le point sur ses
résultats dans les yvelines la première
tout d'abord première circonscription
alors ce dimanche on joue on a senti les
répliques du séisme la république en
marche jusqu'à la première
circonscription des yvelines à droite
depuis à 1963 le territoire est sur le
point de basculer
didier peschard candidat de la
république en marche élue d'opposition à
versailles et réalisé 42,15 % il devance
le grand favori de cette élection le
candidat des républicains le versailles
et françois-xavier bellamy qui ne
totalise que 27 49 % des voix on écoute
la réaction de didier baichère c'est pas
une surprise qui est une bonne surprise
c'est le changement qui est en train de
s'opérer à versailles ce qui montre la
transformation c'est le résultat de
versailles on est au coude à coude il ya
500 voix d'écart je crois entre entre
les deux premiers
la ville change je pense que les
progressistes les sociaux démocrates qui
sont finalement l'image des yvelines
depuis des années eu une droite ou des
centristes modéré je pense qu'il ya un
vrai barrage à la droite
ultra-conservatrice c'est ça le message
de ce soir didier baichère qui réalise
son plus gros score à montigny le
bretonneux 48,72 % des voix principale
surprise sur la ville de versailles le
républicain françois-xavier bellamy ne
devance finalement didier baichère que
de deux petits points ils l'emportent
39,18 % contre 37 09 % pour le candidat
de la république en marche un scénario
pas du tout attendu
voilà wilfried on pouvait sentir une
certaine tension ce dimanche soir à
versailles françois xavier bellamy était
persuadé de réaliser un très bon score
dans sa commune où il est adjoint au
maire en charge de l'enseignement
secondaire et supérieur de la jeunesse
et de l'emploi sur le plan électoral la
dynamique était clairement en faveur des
républicains dans la commune en avril
dernier françois fillon était arrivé
largement en tête au premier tour des
présidentielles avec près de 43% à des
suffrages malgré les affaires alors qu
emmanuel macron le totalisé que 27 % des
votes
une grosse déception donc mais pour
françois xavier bellamy rien n'est perdu
on les écoute alors beaucoup d'électeurs
on pensait que l'élection était jouée
d'avancé
peut-être parce qu'il le réseau mais
avec des critères
des élections précédentes moi je crois
qu'effectivement cette élection allait
être difficile je crois aussi qu elle
est gagnable
je crois toujours qu'elle est gagnable
on va faire tout ce qu'il faut pendant
une semaine pour mobiliser clairement
les électeurs et pour leur montrer que
d'un côté il ya un projet il ya un
projet pour la france et un deuxième
tour on a on a eu beaucoup d'abstention
à ce premier tour cette abstention est
les lieux aussi au fait que voilà
beaucoup d'électeurs se sont sentis peu
concerné par ce qui se passait on a une
semaine pour leur faire comprendre que
ce qui se passe les concerne vraiment et
que c'est leur avenir qui est en jeu
c'est le maire de versailles le député
sortant françois de mazières qui avait
adoubé en quelque sorte françois-xavier
bellamy quelle a été sa réaction alors
sur résultat était forcément très mal
vécu par l'ancien député qui avait
emporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
+2 56% des voix
cette fois ci l'avait choisi de ne pas
se représenter pour se consacrer à son
mandat de maire de versailles
l'homme politique avait donc décidé de
laisser la place à la nouvelle
génération et un françois xavier à
bellamy qui l'a soutenu tout au long de
la campagne françois de mazières était
au micro de tv fil 78
on est face à une sorte de tsunami
nationale aujourd'hui est très important
que sur la circonscription
première des yvelines on arrive tout
même avoir un candidat qui
n'appartiennent pas à cette chambre a
trouvé le fait d'avoir une femme en
trouva avec un show très mauvais y
compris pour le président république et
donc française bellamy peut encore être
réglés et je pense que les gens doivent
se mobiliser pour nous nous ne voulons
pas qu'il y ait que des candidats de en
marche c'est très mauvais pour la
démocratie
les autres résultats les autres
candidats sur cette première
circonscription alors derrière didier
baichère françois-xavier bellamy tous
les deux qualifiés pour le second tour
on retrouve la france insoumise
représenté par thibaut marshall qui
récolte 8 0 4% des voix
le fonds national de thierry perez
arrivent quatrièmes sur la
circonscription avec 5 0 7%
deux points de moins qu'en 2012 mais la
contre performance est surtout à mettre
au crédit du parti socialiste qui
totalise seulement 4 64% des suffrages
alors que le ps était deuxième en 2012
avec 31% des voix au premier tour et 43
25 % au second on écoute la candidate
charlotte c'est fini alors c'était pas
la même dynamique
on avait même un président de gauche on
sait très bien que les personnes
de voter
dans la continuité des présidentielles
franchement sur la circonscription
à versailles à montigny ça va être très
compliqué pour parti socialiste
mais les valeurs restent cela vous savez
une partie c'est juste une éthique à
temps après quand on a des combats à
mener que ce soit sur une éthique et à
tous une autre et combats sont quand
même là et là il va être encore plus
fort à noter wilfried que la france
insoumise le parti socialiste et le
front national n'ont pas encore donné de
consigne de vote pour le second tour
aura-t-on le droit à une nouvelle
réplique du séisme dimanche prochain
avec la victoire de la république en
marche didier baichère réponse ce
dimanche 18 juin dans la soirée
merci michael nous poursuivons ce tour
des résultats dans les yvelines des
différentes circonscriptions édition
spéciale sur tv fils et le scénario a
été le même dans la 2e circonscription
est là aussi c'est le candidat de la
république en marche qui termine en tête
du premier tour jean noël barrot de
vence
le député sortant candidat des
républicains pascal thévenot les autres
candidats sont aussi largement à
distance et point complet avec mélanie
poquet annonces douloureuses pour pascal
thévenot
le député sortant donne les résultats de
sa commune vélizy villacoublay
un an seulement après son élection il
voit son siège s'éloigner ici aussi
c'est le candidat de la république en
marche qui arrive en tête quand on voit
la macro magna qui a aujourd'hui il
suffit qu'ils traversent en fait à
chaque fois tout est miraculeux non je
pense que si on peut pas comparer les
choses et l'élection il ya un an a été
fait sur un projet sur un territoire
là on le voit quel que soit le candidat
de toute façon les gens ne votent pas
pour un candidat votre pour donner une
majorité présidentielle et on le voit
même dans d'autres circonscriptions donc
là il faut simplement à réussir à
remobiliser les 50%
deux personnes qui sont pas allés voter
une tendance confirmée dans presque
toutes les communes de la 2e
circonscription
à l'issue de ce premier tour pascal
thévenot recueil -2 23% des suffrages
l'ingénieur chercheurs de 34 ans termine
en tête de ce premier tour
jean-noël barrot le candidat rer obtient
43 84 %
on n'avait pas vraiment du chiffre en
tatar bien sûr c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour nous ce soir mais on va
continuer à faire ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent c'est à dire comme le
disait robert j'ai d'ailleurs une
campagne positive où on essaye de faire
un certain nombre de propositions qui
sont qui sont en partie celle qu'a porté
emmanuel macron c'est ce qu'on va
continuer de faire cette semaine
dix sept candidats se présentaient sur
la 2e circonscription le front national
représenté par yasmine belmadi se classe
cinquième avec -2 6% des voix loin du
score réalisé par marine le pen lors du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle même tendance du côté de
la france insoumise marc soriano termine
troisième du scrutin avec 7% des voix
le 23 avril jean luc mélenchon obtenait
plus de 13% des suffrages
le résultat au niveau local pour moi
c'est très positif la france insoumise
représente la première force de gauche
on est loin derrière le deuxième mais on
est devant le l'attelage verts
communistes socialistes et devant donc
les mouvements enfin les partis qui
représentent des appareils les chiffres
santé fous sont sont absolument
effrayant pour quelqu'un qui connaît pas
du tout la circonscription qui a été bon
élève à hec mais bon je pense pas que ce
soit suffisant
deux candidats sont donc qualifiés pour
le second tour de ces élections
législatives parmi les battus aucune
consigne de vote n'a été donnée 3e
circonscription qui n'échappe pas à la
vague et république en marche pourtant
c'est une circonscription historiquement
à droite la candidate d'emmanuel mâcon
béatrice pire on s'est même qualifié dès
le premier tour nicolas nouveau revers
qui pourrait se profiler pour le
candidat des républicains philippe
brillault presque qualifiés restent des
le dès le premier tour regardez cette
infographie on va voir tout de suite le
score est définitif sur cette troisième
circonscription plus de 47% du coup pour
béatrice piron la candidate de la
république en marche a été proche du
coup de se qualifier dès le
mais tour le candidat ait l'air est très
loin à 25% clairement c'est une surprise
sur cette circonscription ancrée à
droite depuis longtemps il ya cinq ans
par exemple henri guaino candidat ump
était arrivé en tête du premier tour
avec 28% des voix ce qui lui avait
permis de remporter largement le second
tour à plus de 60% c'était en 2012
cinq ans plus tard le second tour semble
quasiment joué même si béatrice pire on
appelle à la mobilisation des électeurs
sur cette circonscription l'abstention a
atteint 44% dimanche
écoutez là je crois que rien est acquis
d'avancé
on a aussi quand même constaté qu'il y
avait un petit peu plus attention que
d'habitude
donc même si on est au dessus de la
moyenne nationale on est quand même en
dessous d'eux
des scores habituels pour une
législative donc on sait que sûrement
peut-être que quelques électeurs sur la
semaine prochaine seront nouveau sur sur
ces élections et que ça peu un petit peu
faire
un flux et les résultats mais on nous
sommes quand même très confiant et
nicolas vous le disiez principales
victimes si on peut dire de cette vague
république en marche c'est le candidat
des républicains
oui même s'il est qualifié pour le
second tour on voit clairement
difficilement comment ils pourraient
combler son retard
il termine second sur les 13 villes de
la circonscription béatrice pire on
dépasse même les 50 % sur six d'entre
elles et preuve de l'ampleur du
mouvement la république en marche je
termine première sur la ville du chesnay
celle où philippe brillault est maire
depuis 1989 c'est c'est une déconvenue
clairement pour lui qui tente sa chance
pour la sixième fois pour la députation
philippe brillault reste malgré tout
mobiliser il en appelle à tous les
électeurs pour former un front anti
macron écoutez le il faut absolument que
dans les jours qui viennent
les électeurs qui ne sont pas venus
voter viennent voter que ceux qui ont
voté autre chose qu en marche se
mobilisent autour du deuxième candidat
sur l'ensemble des circonscriptions qui
n'est pas en marche
quelle que soit sa couleur politique
quoi qu'on pense de lui
c'est un rassemblement qui devient
quelque part un front républicain pour
les législatives
comme nous l'avons fait pour les
présidentielles il n'y a pas de raison
que ce soit dans un sens unique et
philippe brillault parler aussi hier
soir d'un choix crucial je cite entre
une monarchie une dictature est une
république
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré dans son
discours hier soir en mairie du chéné il
ya encore un second tour les électeurs
vont-ils ou non se mobiliser c'est là
tout l'enjeu pour savoir si oui ou non
la victoire est déjà acquise dans cette
circonscription comme dans les autres on
le rappelle dans les douze
circonscriptions la république en marche
et en tête mais il ya un second tour et
la participation endredi a été faible
les autres candidats dans la troisième
alors cette circonscription s'est
vraiment joué à deux les autres
candidats sont tous en dessous de la
barre des 6% vous le voyez à l'écran
quatre candidats se tiennent en moins de
2000 voix à peu près la france insoumise
le front national le ps et le parti
chrétien démocrate
écoutez à ce propos le candidat de la
france insoumise arrivé 3e alexandre
langlois il félicite notamment ses
opposants politiques pour la qualité de
la campagne écoutez le sur la troisième
circonscription je trouve que c'était
honorable pour tous les candidats
c'est qu'il ya eu des débats de fond n'y
a pas eu des prises
position en disant lui l'a fait si il a
fait ça mais c'était vraiment un débat
d'idées et que je pense que tous les
candidats que j'ai pu rencontrer dans
les débats on est animé de faire le
mieux possible pour la population avec
des programmes bien sûr différent et des
options différentes mais s'était tiré
par le haut le débat donc c'était je
pense qu'à des choses qui pourront
s'inscrire dans l'avenir
en discutant tous ensemble pour savoir
ce qu'elles mieux même si c'est un
candidat dans marche ou des républicains
qui les pivots finale et dernières
informations concernant les deux villes
de l'agglomération villepreux et les
clés sous voit les écarts sont
conséquents là aussi près de trente
points d'écart à chaque fois entre
béatrice piron et philippe brillault sur
les deux villes ce serait donc une
nouvelle grosse surprise de voir les
choses bouger dimanche prochain entre
les deux finalistes merci nicolas nous
revenons à présent sur le scrutin dans
la 10e circonscription des yvelines vous
le savez nous nous intéressons
principalement est ce qui se passe dans
le sud du département la 10e
circonscription la république en marche
remporte ce premier tour devant les
républicains
elle détaille avec vous nicolas landry
le duel annoncé aura donc lieu dans la
10e aurore bergé d'un côté face à jean
frédéric poisson effectivement wilfried
aurore bergé candidate de la république
en marche est arrivé largement en tête
du premier tour avec plus de 46% des
voix
elle sera opposé au candidat du parti
chrétien-démocrate investi par les
républicains jean frédéric poisson
placer en seconde position en totalisant
19 pouces % des suffrages et pour le
député sortant engagés dans cette
circonscription depuis deux législatures
ce score est vécue comme une déception
je vous propose de l'écouter
une terrible gifle
c'est une forte incompréhension pour moi
une forme d'humiliation aussi très
clairement parce que j'ai passé
des années au service de ce territoire
au service de ses habitants de ces
communes
le fait que ce travail ne soient pas
reconnus dans les urnes veut dire une
forme d'ingratitude de la population que
je ne comprends pas maintenant il reste
un second tour il y a beaucoup de
des lecteurs à re mobiliser pour ce pour
ce second tour je pense que les français
rééquilibreront l'assemblée nationale
comme ils l'ont fait dans les élections
législatives précédentes
et si on détaille un petit peu plus le
score de la république en marche et
d'aurore berger prenons par exemple les
deux plus grosses communes de la
circonscription avec rambouillet
maurepas où elle dépasse les 40%
elle atteint même 50 6% des voix dans la
commune de la queue-lez-yvelines une
satisfaction pour la candidate elle est
en ballottage favorable pour le week-end
prochain
on a fait une campagne pour pour le
président de la république et le projet
de réforme qu'on a envie de voir mises
en oeuvre pour le renouvellement
politique et le renouveau démocratique
et puis on a fait une campagne données
de terrain on n'a pas fait une campagne
de notables on est allé voir les gens
dans les écoles dans les gares chez eux
on a essayé de les mobiliser partout
tous les jours parce que 24 heures sur
il faut qu'il vienne se mobiliser et
qu'il vienne le 10 juin prochain viens
on va continuer on va continuer à
collaborer les projets ensemble
on va continuer les concertations va
continuer les réunions et on va
continuer à aller vers eux plutôt que
d'attendre qu'ils viennent vers nous
c'est ça qu'on va changer de manière
durable dans ce département est partout
en france
première force de gaulle dans la
circonscription la france insoumise
bages un nicoletta arrive en troisième
position
en totalisant plus de 8% à trois voix
près il prend même la seconde place
devant jean frédéric poisson dans la
commune de coignières comme vous pouvez
le voir à l'image
l'écologiste david jutier prend la
cinquième place et pour le second tour
il prend personnellement position pour
un vote ni droite ni droite le candidat
europe ecologie les verts devancent le
socialiste jean-claude husson
à gauche les consignes de vote sont
différentes en fonction des candidats je
vous propose d'écouter benjamin
nicoletta et jean claude husson sur ce
sujet je peux pas évidemment appelé à
voter or or merger puisqu'on est dans
l'opposition et qu'on veut se battre
contre ça mais jean frédéric poisson ça
me pose un gros problème puisque c'est
quand même un mouvement qui est ancré à
droite radicale j'ai appelé à battre
jean frédéric poisson parce que j'ai
travaillé avec lui à l'agglomération et
qu' il y avait beaucoup de choses à dire
contre sa manière de faire qui est
totalement inacceptable
autre formation politique qui a souffert
pendant ce scrutin ce premier tour c'est
le front national ça s'est confirmé
aussi sur cette 10e circonscription
effectivement wilfried lefrançois le hot
obtenu près de 8% des voix
il termine à la 4e place derrière la
france insoumise pour le second tour il
appelle à voter contre la candidate de
la république en marche pour je le cite
contrer le programme européen de
dérégulation économique et de réforme de
la structure familiale du côté de
philippe chevrier le candidat du front
libérer la consigne de vote semble la
même et il appelle directement à voter
pour jean frédéric poisson alors au
total c'est près d'eux
56e son prêt par don de 56 % des
électeurs de la 10e circonscription qui
se sont déplacés ce dimanche 11 juin
une participation en baisse de cinq
points par rapport aux élections
législatives de 2012
merci à nicolas d'andry autres
circonscriptions la onzième à présent
l'ex candidat à la présidentielle benoît
hamon ne sera pas au second tour des
législatives il a annoncé lui même qu'il
était battu dans cette circonscription
il n'obtient que 22 61% des voix nadia
république en marche arrive en tête
suivi par jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt qui a déjà été député et qui
avait été battu en 2012 par benoît hamon
retour sur ce premier tour de scrutin
avec stéphane servant sévère défaite
hier soir pour benoît hamon député
sortant de la 11e circonscription devant
des militants abattus rassemblés dans
son fief de trappes
il est venu leur annoncer qu'il eut
manqué plus d'une centaine de voix 165
exactement il n'obtient que 7400 36 voix
soit 22 59% des suffrages exprimés
une brève déclaration un mot de
réconfort aux uns et aux autres
même son ami maire de trappes étaient
sous le choc
une déception j'ai demandé jeudi comme
ça j'ai demandé à benoît pour les
élections législatives précédentes il ya
cinq ans de venir avec nous de
travailler avec nous donc il avait été
élu député il était conseiller municipal
après il a eu du ministère et ses mots
c'est pas ça qui est important ici à
trappes il fait un excellent simple le
vrai montré de très devant devant devant
mais la circonscription est complexe et
composé de ville plutôt beaucoup plus à
droite que la ville de trappes et je
viens d'apprendre comme vous que ça
passait pas pour le second tour quelques
voix près pas content il n'a pas pu
résister à la vague république en marche
qui a tout balayé dans le département
dans la 11e circonscription nadia et
obtient ainsi dit 1858 voix soit 32 98 %
des votes et arrive nettement en tête
devant le candidat
les républicains à l'image des résultats
des législatives de 2012 qui avait vu la
victoire de benoît hamon
dans le sillage de l'élection de
françois hollande
la candidate en marche profitent elles
aussi pleinement des résultats de la
présidentielle
je suis satisfaite du résultat je vois
que les habitants de la circonscription
nous ont placés en tête
donc ils réitèrent leur confiance auprès
du président emmanuel macron et il
m'accorde aujourd'hui la leur au premier
tour donc oui je suis contente elle sera
opposé au candidat des républicains
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
qui fut député avant de perdre son
mandat il est à 5 ans battu par benoît
comme tous les autres candidats
républicains du département ils
s'attendaient sûrement à récupérer ou
remporté son siège à l'assemblée avec
7600 une voix soit 23 de 0 9% des
votants
il résiste mais avec 10 points d'écart
il reste loin derrière
il ne peut même pas espérer exercer une
force d'opposition à l'assemblée qu'il
faut que les gens se soucient de de
l'equilibre dimanche prochain en ciel
pas un minimum d'équilibré qui est plus
de décembre est national et plus de
travail d'assemblées nationales réelles
c'est que les technocrates qui ont pris
tous les pouvoirs balle à vous et vous
allez avoir quand même des surprises on
pas de réunion publique prévue dans
l'entre-deux-tours jean michel fourgous
veut se concentrer sur un débat d'entre
deux tours qu'il espère avec nadia et
pour le reste des candidats mathurin les
vis de la france
insoumise recueille 8 65% des voix et
mathilde andrew et pour le fn 7,03 % des
voix ces deux partis ne réussissons pas
à conserver leur score du premier tour
de la présidentielle un scrutin marqué
par un fort taux d'abstention dans les
yvelines
à peine mieux qu'au niveau national dans
la circonscription les abstentions ont
représenté 59 87 % des inscrits le tour
des résultats dans les yvelines se
poursuit douzième et dernière
circonscription là aussi république en
marche en tête devant le député sortant
ancien ministre david douillet a sauvé
la précédente présidentielle presse
différentes présidences pardon nicolas
sarkozy point sur les résultats
réactions des candidats la 12e
circonscription des yvelines fief du
républicain david douillet pourrait bien
basculer du côté de la république en
marche
florence granger investi par le
mouvement des manuels macron a obtenu 41
0 2% des suffrages exprimés contre 26
93% pour le
et sortants un résultat qui prouve
bien la demande de renouvellement de la
classe politique
selon la candidate marcheuse elle même
issue de la société civile c'est sa
première élection comme au national
on a une comment dire une volonté de
changement et qui s'est traduite de la
part des électrices et des électeurs
on voit qu'il ya quand même une volonté
de renouvellement des visages des usages
comment comme on l'a déjà dix ans
maintenant compte on se dit qu'on va
toujours prudent parce que ce n'est que
le premier tour des élections parce que
on a comment dire des résultats qui font
bien évidemment qui font pas confirmé un
résultat à confirmer surtout compte tenu
du faible taux de participation dans
cette circonscription comme dans le
reste de la france seulement un électeur
sur deux s'est déplacé aux urnes un taux
d'abstention pointé du doigt par
l'ensemble des parties notamment france
insoumise son candidat antoine barreau
est arrivé troisième avec presque 10 %
des voix il se dit déçu de ne pas avoir
mobilisé les électeurs
cela est vraiment qu'il ya une vraie
après la france un soul c'est une vraie
force d'opposition de gauche
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs que dans
certaines circonscriptions là au château
est difficile un regroupement qui aurait
peut-être pu profiter au parti
socialiste en 2012 il avait récolté 34 %
des voix au premier tour
cette année il se hisse derrière le
front national avec 5,16 % les élections
législatives depuis 15 ans depuis 2002
ne sont qu'un reflet
des élections présidentielles donc je
savais très bien que je ne pourrai pas
gagner
néanmoins ce qui m'intéressait justement
c'est que vive la démocratie
un français une française sur deux en
âge de voter ne va pas voter et en fait
c'est le vrai problème pour notre
démocratie
selon les prévisions la république en
marche et le modem arriverait en tête
dans toutes les circonscriptions du
département
les différents candidats s'accordent sur
l'importance de la mobilisation pour le
second tour il invite les électeurs à se
manifester
même pour voter blanc malgré nos
sollicitations ce lundi david douillet
n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview
voilà pour ce tour d'horizon des
résultats quelques mots concernant les
autres circonscription des yvelines les
duels vont donc opposé des sortants de
droite dans la plupart des cas avec des
candidats de la république en marche
on notera dans la 8e circonscription
celle demande que le front national avec
françois simeoni un responsable du
mouvement dans les yvelines est
troisième avec 15% michel vialay se
qualifie 17,2 pour cent est derrière
khadidja mounib de la république en
marche avec 24 29 % autre information le
responsable départemental du modem bruno
myle yen qui est aussi conseiller
régional est qualifiée face au sortant
les républicains jean-marie têtards
respectivement 37,8 et 20 véhicules 3%
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
édition retrouvez sur notre site
internet notre application mobile
également ainsi que tous les détails des
résultats
la campagne de l'entré deux tours est à
suivre sur tv fil 78 avant la nouvelle
soirée électorale avec les journalistes
de la rédaction qui seront une nouvelle
fois sur le terrain à très bientôt sur
tv fils
[Musique]